hi my producer of the year you write you
sing you dance and you produce why is it
important that you do all of those
things
because it's all part of doing a project
and at the end of the day the the more
you know
the better you can after and create a
project so to me it's always been about
that
you take a lot of risks it's always it's
always been about you know how can I
make my music that really represents
what I want to explain in that moment so
that's why it's important to know how to
produce and how to drive what I have in
my mind you do it so incredibly I have
had lie like you love me on repeat for
the last month
it is so amazing to hear you singing a
little in English are there plans to do
a full-length English song A full-length
English album
you never know
everything can happen you never know but
for now I'm very happy with lilac you
love yes how it feels it was organic to
that one so we will see in the future
how did that how did that come about the
idea to start singing in English because
that's a big step in a career I mean in
my first album I did a version yes of a
song in English
but you know it was like something that
I was it was time that it that I wanted
to do it it was long ago I wanted to do
this but I didn't force it but I've been
spending more time and more years here
in the US and that made me feel like
okay now I understand better the
language so now I can write better oh my
gosh you're my babe tonight
thank you so much
[Music]